just because you love to show every
single thing because she likes to show
every single thing I don't like what you
do clearly cuz that's our job it's not
it's not our trying is your it's theirs
yeah there's a fine line Kim and Khloe
Kardashian confront Kourtney over being
too secretive should I just be a
buzzkill in a sneak peek at Keeping Up
with the Kardashians kim and khloe
ambushed their older sister at a private
house where they think she's meeting a
man I'm not literally dating anybody but
we don't know because we don't know
anything about you what if I actually
was then what like you bring the cameras
here it's so disrespectful and be on
camera if I have boundary ISM respect
them well the girls aren't exactly
feeling quartz boundaries our job is
being open and honest and sharing a lot
of ourselves and it just seems like for
the past few years now Kourtney hasn't
really been open about her personal life
on camera so all of the days that
Courtney isn't filming Khloe and I are
picking up the slack and having to share
more because if we're not sharing our
lives then what is the show that's when
court says there's one topic that is
strictly off-limits when it comes to her
and the family's hit show I said I will
not share my relationship not saying I
would rather die never a thing okay but
I shared my breakdown crying about
having anxiety
I share other things you shared that
that happened naturally all right but
I'm not like turn the cameras off this
is so crazy if they wanted privacy I
would never follow them or like expose
them courts last known relationship was
with model eunice Benjamin the two were
first linked in 2016 then split in 2018
and get this the two were spotted
hanging out at a Miami club together on
Wednesday but don't get too excited
a source tells et that they are not
dating again ladies were
you're single at the same time right now
are you double is there like a double
Kardashian date ever
no you really don't I wouldn't think
there'd be like a double setup well I'm
not really dating right now yeah I
should double set them up like on a
blind date I don't think we do dates or
blind dates I don't mind dating but on a
blind date so why do both you are not a
good eater no I don't come from like
friendly group settings et recently sat
down with the famous sisters and they
opened up about living that single life
I'm just super happy and content and I'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and the soul and true and I
just I'm having so much fun with her and
what I want to I will it's not some
deliberate thing that I think that hard
about do you think about it I am also in
a space where I just don't care to
distract with you know I'm not like I
don't know I'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens but I'm not
like thinking about I'm not putting my
energy there Courtney also opened up
about those rumors that she's ready to
quit the show you mentioned that you
might be ready to say goodbye to Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there but
I'm not saying goodbye do you think the
show can continue going if you lose a
sister we definitely love Courtney and
we will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but people come people go
all the time this family we are feel
like it's a revolving door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back
[Music]